at buzzfeed if you ever do a reading
first tweets video with james mcavoy i
just want him to know that he could run
me over with a truck and spit in my face
and i thank him for it thanks for coming
to my ted talk wow i just hope we can
figure out a safe way to do that without
killing you hello there i'm james mcavoy
i'm here with buzzfeed i'm talking about
my son in which i play a guy looking for
his son and i'm going to be reading
thirsty tweets
not to be dramatic but light was
invented to shine through windows and
eliminate james tracker boy's eyes
oh dear god i don't think that's
dramatic i think that's just you being
really uh poetically creative i like
that and i agree every time i hear it's
weird saying my own name every time i
hear james mcavoy's accent i kind of
fall in love with him a little bit more
thank you very much i wish everybody
felt that way they don't unfortunately i
think a lot of people when they hear my
accent go what's that what's that
strange noise coming out of his mind
james mcavoy's accent oh my god spank me
with it holy hell if i could spank you
with my accent i would i promise you but
it's just not possible because it's not
a physical thing oh yeah i suppose it is
vibration isn't it important sound maybe
it can be spanked by vibrations like
that
i'll do my best james mcavoy licking his
finger on bake off after i've been
cooped up inside for a year should be
illegal
perhaps but luckily we live in a world
where it's been legalized and therefore
it can be controlled if any ladies
interested james mcavoy is on the great
british bake off saying things like it
feels a bit wet it felt a bit wet i
think i needed it
too long making it a bit wet the best
part of it chapter two was james
mcavoy's thighs in those jeans really oh
my goodness well thank you i won't be
dynamics i've been told not to but thank
you very much that's very nice what was
it about those were they tight i had
been working out there was a gem in my
building and i was doing sports so i'm
glad somebody noticed never been more
jealous of a bike seat than the scene in
it two where the bike seat scoops up
james mcavoy's butt thanks the bike seat
was consensual we had an intimacy coach
uh come in and make sure that the seat
and i
felt comfortable with the contact that
we were simulating but ultimately it
ended up being a really beautiful scene
why talk about politics when you can
look at james mcavoy but instead i think
that's what most politicians have been
doing during this pandemic uh mr tumnus
was so hot to me as a kid why i wanted
to suck his hooves
so bad
if who've suckered no listen was this
because you're running mr tumnus or is
this just because you're any bestiality
in general and you go down that whole
rabbit hole when you go on the search
engines you know what i mean hopefully
it was just a mr tumbler specific thing
very excited to see glass
so that every time james mcavoy spits i
can pretend like it's going in fine
oh my goodness do i spit a lot i think
i'm like
i think i might be quite a spitty actor
i've got nothing to say that really
spitting in your mouth wow i would let
james mcavoy break my back like a glow
stick
wow so what happens when i break your
back do you become alive with light with
phosphorescence i think so i would
literally crawl through the sahara
through the antarctic through the amazon
and over the himalayas with no food or
water for a taste of james mcavoy's
delft beard oh i just shaved off shaved
off like two days ago sorry about that
i've only heard the term death a little
while ago and thanks very much for using
it in connection with me i appreciate it
i would like james mcavoy rearrange my
insights to be honest kids kiss
fantastic i'm a very good interior
decorator so i'd love to don't mind me
just a hole for jake's microphone
oh my god
oh my god i mean there's nothing to say
for that there's nothing to say about
that except um
oh my god last but not least i would
just say
this one time and one time only james
mcavoy please murder my [ __ ] any time
there's been a lot of violence guys
there's been a lot of violence you know
it's an instinct that's in us all i just
hope like i said to one of the previous
thrusters i just hope that we can get to
a place in our relationship where we can
do that safely and when after it's all
said and done and perpetrated we still
feel respected
thank you very much for watching
buzzfeed and my first tweets uh i've
been here talking about this stuff in
aid of my son which is an improvised
thriller which is on peacock right now
you can stream it for free
uh